the hacker behind the 2016 Democratic
National Committee breach now claims to
have hacked the Clinton Foundation and
there is every indication that at least
some of these screenshots that have been
released are absolutely and completely
fake the statement from I guess it's
pronounced guccifer two point oh I think
it's funny to say Gucci for I don't know
i think i'm gonna keep saying gucci for
cuz it just sounds better to me uh
saying quote hillary clinton and her
staff don't even bother about the
information security it was just a
matter of time to gain access to the
Clinton Foundation server I do hate to
throw sour milk into your coffee here
but at least some of these hacks seem to
be completely fake uh there's a folder
of contacts in these hacks supposedly
called pay to play and this is a
reference to the Securities and Exchange
Commission rules which prohibit the
paying of government officials which
then later might have other benefits
that are provided by a government
official pay to play pay to participate
uh there's something odd about actually
having a folder called pay to play and
here's a tweet from tech reporter Joe
Bernstein who also found this odd saying
it seems extremely fake that the Clinton
Foundation would name a folder pay to
play yeah i mean if if i were bribing
people right for just as an example I
wouldn't have a folder on my desktop
called bribes where I have the list of
bribes inside of it right I mean it
seems a little silly and the data itself
already is is stretching credibility
credulity is pretty significantly and
the entire others a folder called
pay-to-play yet even at the Clinton
Foundation they called what they were
doing play to play they named a folder
that I just doesn't really make too much
sense to me the Clinton Foundation did
make a statement to Politico they said
quote once again we still have no
evidence that Clinton Foundation systems
were breached and have not been notified
by law enforcement of an issue none of
the folders or files shown are from the
Clinton Foundation now Gucci fur or
guccifer two point O responded to
skepticism about the legitimacy of the
breach by claiming that more
files will be released here's a tweet
from guccifer to point o saying
surprised that the DNC d-triple-c DSCC
and h fa docks were on the Clinton's
private server this is just a tiny part
of files keep following me I'm sort of
surprised that people aren't being more
skeptical about this there may be a mix
of real and fake files it's sort of
unclear right now but something about
this just does not seem quite right and
the hill makes a note that some of the
files actually seem to originate from
the DNC see the Democratic National
Campaign Committee rather than the
Hillary rather than the Clinton
Foundation so a lot of questions here
it's very early on but when I saw here's
the folder called pay to play hard to
believe very very hard for me to believe
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s